DeSantis isn't going around on podcasts
anywhere so he's finally learning I
guess now but he seemed to be allergic
to it oh man Vivek is hitting the nail
on the head with a hammer he's been
going on every podcast he can he went on
Alex Stein's live show and that got
asked about 911 they're using that
against him yeah but vivek's just like
I'll go on anyone's show like let's get
the word out I think Vivek understands
the balkanization of media spaces and
Bobby Kennedy absolutely yeah both of
them uh I mean oh yeah he's a podcast
they're going to play a huge role yeah
in this election yes obviously I can't
remember if it was vague or Larry Elder
that week that we had both of them on
but one of them was talking about doing
the podcast like a podcast style thing
like fireside chat from the Oval Office
like it is cool to see these people
Embrace new media especially as we can
see I don't know that fox will ever go
completely away all entirely but it
doesn't have the power it used to